الاجواء وترقب وحذر تعيشها العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس دعوات عشوائيه للتظاهر
يستجيب لها الطلاب وتحشد لها الشرطه
قواتها امام مقر البرلمان
مستفيدين من ورشات صيانه في ساحه
الكونكورد امام البرلمان صنع المتظاهرون
حواجزهم ووضعوها امام الشرطه
هتفوا لاسقاط الرئيس وغنوا باجواء
احتفاليه اشعل النيران وغذو لهيبها ثم
القوا ماكرون مجسم بداخلها
دقائق قليله وتبدا المعركه ازدياد اعداد
المتظاهرين وبلوغها 4000 شخص دفع الشرطه
لفض التظاهر بالقوه رشقات حجاره ومقذوفات
من المتظاهرين الذين احتلوا الساحه لخمس
ساعات ردت عليها الشرطه بالقنابل المسيله
للدموع حتى تمكنت من عزلهم وتقسيمهم الى
مجموعات
ومحاصره كل واحده على حده فاجبرتهم على
المغادره عنوه وكذلك فعلت مع وسائل
الاعلام التي رافقتها عناصر الشرطه للتاكد
من مغادرتها استعاده الشرطه سيطرتها على
الوضع في الميدان مثلا انتصارا صغيرا
لمعركه انتهت اليوم في الشارع وستبدا
الاسبوع المقبل في البرلمان مع اعلان حزب
التجمع الوطني من اقصى اليمين بزعامه مال
لبنان طرح اول مذكره حجب للثقه عن الحكومه
لقد قمنا بطرح مذكره حجب الثقه عن الحكومه
ايضا سنقوم بالتصويت على اي مذكره حجب ثقه
اخرى تطرح من اجل اسقاط الحكومه مذكره
اقصى اليمين لم تكن الوحيده اذ اعلنت كتله
النواب المستقلين طرح مذكره من جهتها
ستصوت عليها قوى اليسار الخمس في البرلمان
مجتمعه
سيكون من المفيد لدينا ان نصوت على مذكره
حجب الثقه لاسقاط قانون رفع سن التقاعد
غير العادل وغير المفيد ذلك سيكون من اجل
حفظ الديمقراطي البرلمانيه والاجتماعيه
والى ان يجتمع البرلمان مجددا يوم الاثنين
المقبل للتصويت على مذكرتي حجب الثقه
ستخيم على شوارع العاصمه مشاهد انتشار
قوات الامن خوفا من امتداد رقعه الحريق
الذي اشعله الرئيس الى كل المدن الفرنسيه
على ما تقول المعارضه
العربيه باريس